person who is extremely passionate about
this issue stopping criminals and saving
lives is dwayne chapman also known as
dog the bounty hunter dog um thank you
so much for joining the program
you're passionate about this what is
your solution
well thank you brother very much we're
starting a campaign right now it's
called
and here's how you get ahold of us take
the let out at gmail.com
i've arrested over 8 000 fugitives in a
43
career and have never shot anyone and
killed them
we've used all non-lethal weapons we're
going to get the lead out of the bullet
and replace it with rubber
and or wood i've shown a thousand
arrests on different networks in america
in the last 15 years
and i've been attacked for anywhere from
machetes
shopping carts guns knives i've shot a
lot but i've never killed
no one because on my team you will not
use a lethal weapon it's not the gun
that kills
or the officer it's the lead in the
bullet
yep dawg when you talk about this a lot
of officers and i know by going through
the police academy
at one point in time they get very
skeptical of things like this even our
own sean hannity has proposed
stuff that's similar to this but
officers think that they need their guns
as well so how do you send that message
to officers that
there is an alternative well they
you know i think a lot of them know that
like right now there's
i doubt if there'll be any officers pull
any kind of weapons
because uh it just doesn't work you
shoot someone right now you got a
problem
so let's take the lead out of the bullet
and let's protect him you've seen me do
it
thousands of times i've you know been
attacked by
armed fugitives felons running at me
and shot many with non-lethal weapons it
works all you need to do is get them
down
so you can cuff them you need to stop
killing them
and i don't think they're killing them
on purpose as you know brother there's
no such thing in america
when you go to police academy as trained
you know train them to wound all police
are trained to kill
so let's take the lead out of their
bullet yeah you know
it's not just police officers that are
trained if you get your chl they teach
you you shoot center mass this is not
an it's very hard to shoot in the leg
and the arm and
all those other parts of your body but
you know real quickly
on this i know we're talking about the
police officers but you're a man of
faith
you love this country you love cops you
love the community how do you think we
can come together
as americans well i think i think this
is a bipartisan bill
who's going to want to keep the lead in
so you can kill someone
who's going to do that and then we'll
separate the men from the boys
i think every cop in america every
citizen we got to stop
them they're coming at you they just
robbed a store or whatever
kidnapping someone you got to stop them
a a
wood bullet a rubber bullet will stop
him just like a lead bullet but they
will not
die of course unless you hit someone
right in the head
you hit someone in the head with
anything and it's going to kill him but
you got to get the lead out of that
bullet dog brother
thank you so much for joining us and
presenting a solution to a difficult
problem
thank you sir i hope you come back thank
you thank you
i dip